can gen Z survive till their parents
arrive according to the Wall Street
Journal owned by our parent company
Cinnabon
young people are entering the workplace
while still clinging to Mommy's apron
job recruiters and hiring managers say
more and more helicopter parents are
involving themselves and their
children's professional lives it's true
just the other day cat's dad told me to
tell his daughter to stop stealing his
ringworm lotion
laughs
but the parents meddling includes
applying for jobs on behalf of their
kids and even sitting in on job
interviews
I know I hear that's how Chris Wallace
got his start
[Laughter]
and sometimes parents even show up at
workplaces to mediate conflicts and
demand raises for their kids
I sure hope those kids give their
parents some of the money for their
efforts
and somehow these 20-somethings don't
instantly drop dead from embarrassment
experts what would we do without them
say these shifting attitudes is due to
the pandemic which caused many young
people to move back in with Mom and Dad
so what is the solution well if you
really want your parents involved in
your employment decisions get a job
where your parents work
thank you
so
Jim you have kids or a kid
right yeah are you still allowed to see
him
the charges are still pending yes would
you what would it look like I mean would
you take your kid to a job interview I
mean when you're younger and let's say
they're like six and he's getting his
first job I can see that but
no when I was 16 my me and my mom went
on the same job interview for this
department store they needed a lot of
help so I was gonna for a stock boy and
she was going to work the floor so we
went in together
which was awkward yeah true story and I
had to work on my mom and she would tell
you know I'd be in hiding out in the
stock room sleeping so I'm going to tell
your boss I'm like you're not my boss
here I can do what I want
but I remember her going tell tell him
how much it was local department store
yeah it's like how much how much you
like Wilco I go I hate it I don't want
to be here I don't want to work here I
only you know I'm only here because
you're making me get a job
it's like what about when I bring you
here tell them how much you love it you
buy me school supplies I hate this place
but I did work when I was in the job and
we both got the job too yeah yeah but it
was awkward yeah I bet it was uh
this is good I feel like I'm in therapy
with you I want because she would find
me sleeping in the stockrooms like wake
up you got to go back out there and work
I'm like shut up you're not my mom here
uh we're out of time uh next week same
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah and do those
exercises I told you to do thank you Cat
hey yeah you're uh is your parents ever
get involved in any of your job things
what do you make of this whole Trend I
just it's unimaginable to me yeah no my
parents would never do I mean I've never
gotten my parents involved my parents
have never want to be involved ever like
I I I would work at restaurants and they
maybe come visit me and say hey how are
you I'll order this food but
what is wrong with the kids too yeah
that they're just like allowing this to
happen for me if I was going to a job
interview and my parent was with me I
would just stop walking yeah like you
know you're not gonna get that job don't
move your feet anymore yeah so other
than like maybe wishing my dead mom
would haunt you no never yeah it is kind
of uh digging it's kind of like you
don't want your parents chaperoning you
on a date and yet you I mean that's
embarrassing I didn't remember you
always if you had to go to the mall to
get school clothes you'd walk behind or
ahead of your mom so people wouldn't see
remember that
what I'm too old for malls
my biggest fights between me and my mom
ever always happened at Kohl's yeah
Kohl's brings out the worst the worst in
people it's because of the cold the
dollars right the Kohl's cash
I
know people
actually had this
this uh somebody's start a girl started
working on the team and two weeks in and
said my mom says I'm not getting enough
praise and accolades as the another
person in the same job who had been
there for years two weeks later she
calls in one morning says I'm not coming
to work because I'm just not getting the
attention and accolades that I deserve
and you could hear a mother in the
background telling her to quit so I
would like to speak to that girl's
mother right now I hope you enjoy living
with your completely useless pain in the
ass daughter who you created from day
one and um and her four kids by three
different men and her current and her
current boyfriend who I'm sure has sold
your Hummel figures to play the slots at
Mohegan Sun go check the garage I bet
your car is gone
Kevin I was going to ask you how you
might react but
well I'll tell you when I started to see
this happen was in the back end of 2020
people forget the pandemic but we were
totally locked down so if you're a
company that sells consumer goods or
services the only way you could sell it
because Amazon shut down for essential
Services they were selling masks and
disinfectant but you couldn't buy
anything else for a while so most
companies tried to hire 20 year olds
that understood social media how to do
Tick Tock how to do Instagram ads how to
do Twitter and so we're interviewing
these people and most people don't know
that their camera on their laptop is
really wide it's a wide shot so there's
mom passing notes in there in the
interview
and you know you could see her shadow on
the wall tell them this tell them that I
just say mom get out here are you going
to do the social media are we hiring the
kid because we didn't know how to do it
we were trying to figure out we used to
hire those guys for like nineteen
thousand dollars now they're 250 000 if
they know what they're doing if you're
really good at social media and
everybody's selling direct consumers
that's when it started but I met a lot
of moms in those days because I had
nothing to do either just interview 20
year olds hey you want to work first
were they hot
well a lot of people weren't wearing
pants
and I want to be honest with you either
was I
that's what the pandemic really killed
the pants the pale pants industry down
the tubes
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else